so yesterday I had a buddy mine Jason
over and we're doing some work and I was
telling me about a mistake that I made
recently and it's like whatever you made
a business mistake how is that possible
you're having Carmichael it's refreshing
to know that you still make mistakes too
and you know I still make mistakes i'm
not perfect you know how you learn is
through making mistakes you make enough
mistakes you learn not to do those same
things again and that's how you get
better that's how you get more
experience I'm able to answer a lot of
your questions because I've made a ton
of mistakes so here's a mistake that I
made recently an old client contacted me
and said hey we'd love to work with you
on this project are you available and i
looked at the project and it didn't
excite me it didn't you know and my god
i felt like ah this is not a right fit
for me but i felt bad for my client I
knew I could help them and so I wanted
to help them so I had these competing
issues right like in my gut I feel like
it's not the right thing for me to do
but at the same time I feel bad and I
know I can help and so I said yes I said
yeah I'll help you out and we came up
with a campaign and it's just been one
problem after another it's been so much
back and forth such a drain on my energy
and and I wish like I can't wait for
this thing to end move on to something
new and what has taught me the mistake
for me is really really really you have
to listen to your gut you know I I want
to be able to help people and I feel bad
but at the end of the day it has to feel
right it's got to be the right deal for
you and this is like this is a small
deal right this isn't a huge maker break
my business kind of deal and what kind
of saved me with my business at the very
start was I had the courage to listen to
my gut to say don't take these high
paying jobs stick with your business
even though it's making zero
the three hundred dollars a month and
that was a really scary decision and I
trusted my gut because I felt like the
right thing to do and so it just
reinforce the fact that when I don't
feel like it's the right thing to do I
shouldn't do it if it doesn't feel good
in your gut don't do it even if it makes
sense logically quantifiably money-wise
even if all that make sense if it
doesn't feel right in your gut don't do
it so that's a lesson that I learned
again this past week and I hope you do
too believe those are you watching like
the video thumbs up below let me know
you think leave a comment ask your
question below make a video response I
love seeing your comments come in so
thank you so much and click on my face
to subscribe to the channel I'll see you
soon